نشاهد دخول
المرشح المعارضه ايضا
كمال
اوكلو والذي يدلي بصوته في احدى لجان
العاصمه التركيه انقره في هذا اليوم
الانتخابي الذي تعيشه تركيا بعد ان فتحت
صناديق الاقتراع ابوابها منذ صباح هذا
اليوم اذا المرشح الرئاسي كما نشاهد
امامنا كمال
يدلي بصوته في احدى لجان انقره كما نتابع
واياكم في هذه الصور
المباشره امامنا من العاصمه التركيه انقره
واخذ ايضا كذلك هذه الصور
لادلائه بصوته ايضا في احدى لجان العاصمه
التركيه انقره مرشح تحالف الامه كمال
كلجدار اوغلو دخل اذا الى هذا المركز والى
احدى اللجان العاصمه التركيه انقره ويدلي
بصوته الان كما نشاهد من خلف الستار في
هذه الصوره امامنا اذا في هذا اليوم
الانتخابي التركي المرشح الرئاسي كمال
كلجدار اوكلو يدلي الان بصوته في احدى
لجان العاصمه التركيه انقره النسب
الاستطلاع كما تابعنا واياكم خلال الايام
الماضيه اشارت في اكثر من مكان الى ان
كمال
أوجلو يتقدم ولو بنسبه طفيفه على منافسه
في هذه الانتخابات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اذا نتابع هذه الصور كما ذكرنا
واياكم للمرشح الرئاسي كمال كالجدار اوكلو
يدلي بصوته في احدى لجان انكر طبعا هو
المرشح الاول من المرشحين الرئاسيين
الثلاثه الذي يدلي بصوته هذا الصباح في
العاصمه التركيه انقره كما نشاهد اهتمام
واسع اذا من وسائل الاعلام هذه اللجنه
تحديدا التي يتواجد فيها كمال
اوكلو للادلاء ايضا كذلك بصوته الزميله
فاطمه فهد كانت تتواجد في ذات اللجنه منذ
الصباح تحدثت عن اقبال كثيف عن فئات عمريه
مختلفه ايضا وصلت الى هذه اللجنه والى
اكثر من لجنه ايضا كذلك في العاصمه
التركيه انقره للادلاء باصواتهم خرج الان
بعد ان ادلى بصوته اذا في احدى لجان انقره
كان كمال كريجدار اوغلو قد وعد
بتحسين الاوضاع الاقتصاديه رفع مستوى
الحريات ايضا كذلك واعاده النظام
البرلماني ايضا الى تركيا
كان قد وصف بانه مهندس التحالفات ايضا
كذلك وهو كما نعلم زعيم تحالف الامه وهو
وجه المعارضه ايضا كذلك الذي يعني يوصف
بانه الوجه الاقوى في المعارضه منذ عشره
اعوام حتى اليوم يدخل هذه الانتخابات وهذا
السباق الرئاسي كذلك ايضا في تركيا الى
جانب كذلك
المرشح اخر الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
مرشح تحالف الشعب وكذلك ايضا مرشح تحالف
الاجداد السنان اوغان اذا مراكز الاقتراع
كانت قد فتحت ابوابها ابوابها في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه ايضا حتى
كذلك وسط
امنيه وكذلك مشدده
وعدد الناخبين ايضا بلغوا ربما اكثر من 64
مليون ناخب المسجلين طبعا في هذه
الانتخابات الان يغادر المرشح الرئاسي
التركي كمال كالجدار اوغلو بعد ان ادلى
بصوته في احدى لجان العاصمه التركيه انقره
وكما ذكرنا قبل قليل كانت يعني وعوده
الانتخابيه ربما عناوين عريضه
لبرمجه الانتخابي بتحسين الاقتصاد برفع
ايضا كذلك
الحريات في تركيا وباعاده النظام
البرلماني ايضا كذلك الى تركيا هو يعتبر
وجه المعارضه الابرز ربما منذ عشره اعوام
يدخل هذا السباق الرئاسي
وكما اشارت استطلاعات الراي بانه تفوق
باكثر من مكان وفي اكثر من استطلاع على
منافسه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
الانسانيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات